let's talk about the bad guys are
winning this is an atlantic story which
is kind of surprising that they're
writing this today's great article yeah
today the most brutal members of
autocracy inc don't much care if their
countries are criticized or by whom the
leaders of iran confidently discount the
views of western infidels the leaders of
cuba and venezuela dismiss the statement
of foreigners on the grounds that they
are imperialist the leaders of china
have spent a decade disputing the human
rights language long used by
international institutions successfully
convincing many people around the world
that these western concepts don't apply
to them russia has gone beyond merely
ignoring foreign criticism to outright
mocking it if america removes the
promotion of democracy from its foreign
policy if america ceases to interest
itself in the fate of other democracies
and democratic movements then
autocracies will quickly take our place
as source of influence funding and ideas
of americans together with our allies
fail to fight the habits and practices
of autocracy abroad we will encounter
them at home indeed they are already
here if americans don't help to hold
murderous regimes to account those
regimes will retain their sense of
impunity they will continue to steal
blackmail torture intimidate inside
their countries as well as inside ours
thoughts
yeah look the title says it all the bad
guys are winning so by default we have
to remember here that in america
we're the freaking good guys
we're the people that the world needs
and it's so easy you know like the trump
interview it's like oh you think we're
so good you don't think we've done
something yeah okay i got that part
right we've not not every we're not not
everything we do is the best thing ever
but without america as the number one
power in the world who takes over china
that's who's that's who we're going to
leave the power of the world in and look
at what they've mentioned in this
article look at the names
iran cuba north korea venezuela china
those are the bad guys those those are
the autocrats something that we need to
um understand we're obviously a
capitalist channel and entrepreneurship
but above that
is democracy there's only one way to do
it though there's only one way to do it
let me let me explain to what i mean by
this so last week we had a meeting in
dallas i'm back to dallas again tomorrow
morning and then i'm back again so i've
been december and january february for
me such a busy season it's great and by
the way we just closed on a new building
yesterday which is exciting for vitamin
but let me tell you what happened when i
was in dallas i'm in dallas last week we
have a meeting
it's a day and a half we start early we
go late
it was the most emotionally intense
meeting we've ever held there's not a
single person that wasn't upset in the
room and there was a single person that
didn't cry in the room very emotional
with the vision what we want to do next
with our company okay
let me tell you what happened
yesterday jose marlin gaitan their
organization their agency that they run
they do around 30 40 million a year
their organization yesterday had an
explosive day on a monday you don't have
explosive days on mondays okay
the language they're speaking is insane
people who disagreed with each other
are now on the same page people who
didn't want to be in the same room
together are now let's go kill the enemy
right
the problem with america on this
[ __ ] article that they write by
freaking atlantic there's 95 other
articles by atlantic that does the
complete opposite [ __ ] of this you
write one article talking about we're so
great you write 94 other articles about
how america is this it's on you the
media so for me rather than saying
something like this why don't we unite
on the common enemy that we have who is
the common enemy
you don't see a common enemy today you
see aoc on one side mentioned on the
other side trump's the enemy in america
the enemy is the opposite political
party that's the biggest problem but
that's caused by the atlantic being part
of the mainstream it's not just atlanta
i'm not saying my enemy is our past
the point i'm trying to make with the
media is as much as the media wants to
write noble articles like this how about
we hold you accountable for having
caused this division in america today
how about we hold you to the fire for
all this [ __ ] you do with journalism
that you have to be held accountable for
you given actual journalistic integrity
you ain't got no journalistic integrity
so you write one article you think
you're all noble now you want to go out
there and talk about this no i think the
problem in america is here today look at
this
china threatens u.s over expected
diplomatic boycott china will take
firm counter measures let me read this
article to see where i'm going with this
part here
so uh uh uh the daily wire the biden
administration is expected to announce
this week that no u.s government
official will attend the 2022 beijing
olympics implementing a diplomatic
boycott of the game cnn reported the
move would allow the u.s to send a
message to the world stage to china
without preventing u.s athletes from
competing foreign minister spokesperson
ministry spokesperson mock the us over
the expected move claiming that they
were never invited anyway but then later
making it a threat without being invited
american politicians keep hyping the
so-called diplomatic boycott or debating
winter olympics which is purely wishful
thinking and grandstanding he said if
the u.s site is bent on going its own
way channel will counter measures take
firm countermeasure senator ted cruz
told cbs news last month that he
supported the diplomatic boycott of the
2022 winner olympics in beijing and u.s
athletes needed to go over to kick their
commies ass right so okay we need stuff
like that
we need a true enemy today to unite the
hell out of america but everybody needs
to be on the same page so for me you
write an article like that great people
like us talk about under podcast people
share with other people but at the end
of the day one article one piece no
america is pretty united right now
because people are pinning people
against each other the whole cuomo
scandal that took place okay with
whatever happened with his brother
that's going back and forth and then it
happens to him and then they found that
he was getting guys on the inside to
work with him then he said he suppressed
the information he's against but here's
the kicker though on what happened the
kicker is all of that stuff that
happened he came out and said i'm sorry
zucker knew and he was helping out as
well what are we talking about here and
then he's going to cnn saying you better
pay me my 18 million or whatever the
number that's left so look at the
debacle of this you know cnn that was a
god agency you know a media company a
year ago two years ago now everybody's
like wait what now don lemon i don't
know if you saw don lemon what came out
this morning about don lemon did you
guys hear about don limits how don lemon
was doing the same thing to what what
chris did to andrew don was doing to
jesse smalling
okay so this whole thing can break down
very quickly but there's more and
there's more but the point i'm trying to
make is the first way we become united
is when media
is held okay
if you went to school to columbia
university to become this wonderful
journalist that you are and you're
superior to us because you got this yell
thing going on or just whatever thing
going on brown thing going on and we
went to glendale community college or
whatever university and college we went
to i'm sorry now it's on you rather than
bullying all of america and dividing
them how about you get held accountable
a little bit and then let's see how you
guys respond aren't they being held
accountable their ratings are going down
and down and down america is waking up
they're listening to them more and more
people
cnn is used as a derogatory term now
online it's like oh you must watch cnn
if you think that so i think in a
certain way
the market is talking the market the
information market is speaking and i
mean you made a lot of great points
about but i i will i will disagree man i
think the atlantic
having that article is a step in the
right direction i agree the people that
listen to the atlantic have never felt
that there's there is a however though
there's a big however though
if you do it one time
just like let me give you an example
what i mean by this you know how
sometimes uh uh a cnn will do an article
to kind of get the republicans to be
like oh i agree you know so then they
bring membership in or like some of
these guys like bill maher did it one
time and republicans are like i agree
with bill finally yeah
but bill mars continues 95 and a half so
if atlantic goes and stays in the middle
and actually reports good for you you
make money you deserve to make money but
if they do this one hit piece to get
attention there yeah even if pat it's a
step in the right direction because
those there's a we both know when it's
on both sides that
you could say something but if they
don't hear it from their side they don't
believe it it's not what you say is who
says it is what you're talking about so
there's there we are not living in in a
simultaneous reality we're living in two
different realities based on ideology
and then even if for one second there's
a crossover that's a step in the right
direction yes for one second that they
say hey look there's an autonomous
regime that has the quote-unquote global
cabal that everybody keeps making fun of
no no it exists that it's real and these
guys want to take over
that's a that's a step in the right
direction that's a step forward i don't
disagree by the way yeah i'm totally
with you however the only thing i would
say is let's see how they follow up the
next month the next three months six
months 12 months
if they go in that direction then go
think about it from this angle okay
think about it from this angle think
about what happened with forbes
i've been a die-hard forbes guy for 20
years go read a forbes article today
it's like wait a minute
you know it's chinese-owned 95 i sold it
i know 95 so you think
you're reading about the great ideas of
capitalism i don't touch forbes i don't
touch 90 of these business magazines
because it's ran by journalists who hate
capitalism yeah yeah so if these guys go
back to certain set of values like let's
just say atlantic says hey folks
let's have a meeting yeah okay let's
just say this is caused by a meeting
that was held you guys had to stand up
you know meeting yesterday right on
monday let's say there's a meeting and
they say
somebody comes out and says guys let's
unify what's the greatest country in the
world well i i i don't know if we can
speculate that you the the dan mark you
you got you know this and you got sweden
all this [ __ ] no no no listen let's
not get it twisted
america is the greatest country in the
world i love that video you did in your
car by the way which one about if
america was a restaurant
if america was a that's right everybody
wants to come yeah yeah so so what i'm
saying to you is if that kind of a
meeting took place with somebody at the
atlantic oh we need more of those well
there's two things that happened also in
the last half hour and actually really
just happened at this table that i
really hope the audience understands
you're talking about narrative all right
and you're talking about common enemy
and the power of a common enemy and the
power of a narrative the narrative
forever has been in our media that the
common enemy in america is america and
it's our past towards the other side no
it's our past no justice on stolen land
how many times have you heard there can
be no justice on stolen land as if every
land every nation ever created wasn't
created through some sort of warfare as
if even even the native americans
themselves didn't shade borders based on
inter-tribal warfare this was always le
nappy land they never fought against the
cherokee are you nuts right conflict
over resources was the entire source of
evolution genghis khan mongolia what are
we talking about here like i ran all
over the world every single nation has
been founded through conflict and
acquisition so we're not the only
country so this idea that every american
1612 project
yeah the idea that everything that's
ever happened in this country is by its
its very good point illegitimate it's
nonsense yeah on its base point yeah and
unless we have somebody from that side
point that out yeah that narrative is
going to be pervasive like that is
freaking to you that that narrative is
not coming from america you know what
it's like but bring it down to the
average person right bring it down to
the average person so let's just say
uh uh uh he and i are brothers
hypothetically we're brothers and we're
two years apart okay we grew up we're
best friends of course we fought we've
done all that other stuff but if i cling
on what he did at 16 years old when he
took my video game away and i keep
reminding them that 42 years old well
listen man you screwed up as well let's
chill out everybody here makes mistakes
so there is a community it's even worse
than that pat it's somebody who looked
like him stole your phone 16 years and
you blame and you're holding him
accountable yeah so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you